hero with a thousand faces what does
this mean in one sense there is a story
that the human being has been repeating
over and over and over ever since we
were able to articulate
stories and at the center of that story
is a heroic
figure we might call that heroic figure
the hero we might call that heroic
figure the heroine we might call that
heroic figure a heroic team or a
collective or
Ensemble but in a
sense the hero with a thousand faces
represents the many many masks that that
heroic presence has put on throughout
history throughout time and throughout
culture amongst groups of people who
have never met each other
around the world there's something in
the energy of that story that continues
to rise up in human beings and I believe
will continue to rise because it speaks
to our own psychological development and
movement as humans and when you say
masks are you talking about sort of the
fact that we all have many sides to us
even someone that's heralded as a saint
can also have sin in them as well
absolutely there are masks that we put
on in order to
um in order to walk through different
seasons of our life sometimes we we must
put on a masks that protects us from the
elements in the hot sun other times
there are masks that are aspirational
they speak to that which we would like
to be
and sometimes when I meet new people I
put on a mask in order to project who I
want them to believe I am the same is
true in storytelling in many ways we
create many characters that represent
one type of Human Experience I'll give
you just a bit of a breakdown of this
many times when we think about
storytelling we forget get that
throughout history there have been a
number of different types of stories
that have served different purposes
there have been myths fairy tales
Parables one of my favorite types of
Storytelling are
fables and fables have a unique
application in The Human Experience in
that when you and I hear a fable we
often identify with a singular character
because we live in a western culture
where we tend to find one character that
we most identify with let's take a fable
like uh the um tortoise in the hair
something a lot of people are familiar
with that this turtle and this rabbit
run a
race and we listen to that story and say
well I guess I need to be like the
turtle slow and steady wins the race and
don't be like the hair who uh becomes
lazy at the
end however when someone like asop would
have shared that story asop would have
recognized that his audience would have
heard that story and saw both of those
characters as being inside of them that
inside of me is both a tortoise and a
hair and sometimes that t CIS energy is
going to be what's important to me but I
also have this hair energy inside of me
and it's about finding the balance and
the way to um to to move with both of
those energies so I think when we talk
about any form of story or storytelling
or mask that we might put on a character
we of so can recognize that in a sense
if I create a story filled with
characters every one of those characters
is an expression of
me Carl Young talked about when we dream
all the characters in our dreams are us
we are represented by each one of those
characters so in a sense every story is
an invitation to go deeper inside
ourselves how do you define a hero
Joseph cble talked about a hero being
someone that was willing to sacrifice
for for something larger than themselves
an idea that's larger than themselves a
principle that's larger than
oneself and I think that in many ways is
how I Define a hero as
well a hero in my opinion is not
necessarily defined by what that
individual
gains but also what they're willing to
give up what they're willing to
sacrifice
in storytelling we often talk about
these four types of endings to any story
where a hero or a protagonist either
gets both what they want and what they
need maybe they get what they want but
not what they need the third type being
they get what they need but not
necessarily what they want and the
fourth a story where the hero gets
neither what they want nor what they
need
and there's examples of each type of of
story throughout uh the history of
Storytelling but when we talk about what
a hero truly
is I think in our culture we're talking
about someone who is willing to give
something up someone that is not so
narcissistic or self- centered that
everything has to become about
them I think in storytelling when we
talk about heroes there's a
psychological need inside of every one
of us to feel like we're a good person
to feel like we too have heroic elements
inside of
us and if we are going to confront those
heroic aspects of our
self we have to be willing to confront
those sacrifices that we may have to
make in
life what am I willing to sacrifice for
what am I willing to give up that which
means a great deal to me in order to
achieve many of us would say well I'm
willing to sacrifice for family or for
those that I love and that's honorable
that's
Noble but what about those who are
willing to sacrifice for those that
they've never
met what about those who are willing to
sacrifice for a
principle that they so strongly believe
in they're willing to lay down their
very life so that that idea might
progress forward for the rest of us I
think most of us would say there's
something heroic about being willing to
do that so when I I think about what a
hero
is it's not simply what someone is able
to achieve externally or what even a
character is able to achieve
externally but it's also about who that
individual is their
character I I think heroism is not
necessarily something that we can see
but we can see see the fruits of it we
see the action that results from heroism
but true heroism lives in the heart it
lives inside of
someone and many times it lives inside
of someone or inside of a character and
they're unaware of it until the
appropriate precise moment opens up the
opportunity for them to fully Express
that heroism that they didn't even know
was living inside of them is every
protagonist a hero it's interesting when
we begin to look at the terms we use for
Central characters in
story sometimes we use the word
protagonist and the word hero
interchangeably other times I think we
are very careful about the words that we
choose when we describe the characters
within a
story this of course opens up discuss
about
anti-heroes and anti-h heroins and we've
we've went through different seasons of
Storytelling where the most interesting
Central characters in a story were
actually characters that didn't
necessarily
embody those characteristics of a hero
that we typically point to so we we have
this era especially in the Golden Age of
television with Tony Soprano and with
Walter Wy in characters like this that
in a sense were anti-heroes they were
what we would have typically called bad
guys and yet they are the central
characters in these stories that we find
ourselves rooting for so when you think
about this idea of whether every
protagonist is a hero I think we have to
ask ourselves a hero to
who I think every Pro an Agonist is a
hero to
themselves and that is what
differentiates them from the other
characters within that story many times
we could tell the same story many many
different ways with the same characters
and who is the hero in that story will
be very different you could tell the
story of Star Wars from the perspective
of Darth Vader it's a very different
story about these
uh rebellions that keep popping up and
challenging Authority and the rebel this
archetypal character of the Rebel well
it might be uh a character that we point
to and say oh that's the good guy in
this story but that same Rebel character
is the villain in someone else's story
so I don't think it ever becomes um easy
to point to who the uh hero is in a
story because it's all about the
perspective on that story uh which
character is going to feel like that
character is a hero which character is
going to feel like that character is a
villain but I think the unifying
principle is that every protagonist to
some degree will see themselves as a
hero now the last thing I'll say about
this and I think this is really
important especially in the age that we
live
in we we often try our best to make the
world black and white without Shades of
Gray This unfortunately is just not true
about the world we live in and it's not
true about us every single one of us has
been the hero and the villain every
single one of us has been the central
protagonist and the
sidekick the mentor and the
contagonist every single one of us has
served multiple roles and this is the
truth it's all Shades of Gray depending
on where we're setting at any given
moment in our perspective of the
story
however the essence of Storytelling
comes down to one person or a group of
people saying this is how I see the
world you can can agree or disagree but
I'm telling you this is what the world
looks like from where I said and we as
an audience are fascinated to see a
singular perspective of someone who
looks at the world and says yeah that's
what the world looks like to me too in a
sense every great story is a mirror that
the audience can look and see themselves
in